before California was the land of fits
bytes and binary it was filled with
fields and people growing fruit
vegetables and flowers my family's
history in this area dates back to pre
World War two had my my
great-grandfather in the area my
grandfather my dad and now myself and
the early stars of California
agriculture for Japanese Americans like
Haru Hayashi whose family owned a farm
in Arroyo Grande
but even though japanese-americans put
food on the nation's table they still
faced discrimination from their
neighbors and their government next day
after Pearl Harbor the FBI came and took
all the head of the family hey guys I'm
Shireen and this Sunday on aj+
we've traded the studio for the fields
to talk about how japanese-americans
helped feed America and the struggles
they faced along the way
[Music]
this is what you will see in a grocery
store wrapped in a plastic wrap four
generations of this japanese-american
family have been farming in Arroyo
Grande for decades my grandfather came
from Japan early 1900s he was 15 years
old
he's farmed up and down the California
coast and he came here in the 1920s to
this area the cabarrus were just one of
thousands of Japanese American families
that historian Donna graves says were
instrumental in shaping California
agriculture in the early 20th century
California became the breadbasket for
the United States in the early 20th
century an immigrant labor was
incredibly important to that especially
the work of Japanese American farmers
Japan had been closed to trade with the
west from the 1600s until the late 1800s
the country's custom of leaving an
inheritance to the eldest son meant
there were many young Japanese men who
were ready to seek their fortunes
elsewhere in the US was in need of
laborers Japanese immigrants had a
chance to lay their roots after the u.s.
implemented a discriminatory policy
aimed at curbing Chinese immigration the
1882 Chinese Exclusion Act cutoff on a
really important source of labor for
California and Japanese immigrants
stepped in to fill that gap Japanese
immigrants took many paths to the u.s.
some came through South America others
through Hawaii at the time a u.s.
territory japanese-americans really
exploited the possibilities for
intensively farming small pieces of land
that were near urban areas they were
willing to do the hard work of creating
a really robust crop in a small plot of
land and then getting it to market my
grandfather actually came over to Hawaii
first on a contract to harvest sugarcane
once that contract was up he came over
to California and harvested I think
sugar beets for the Holly sugar company
and also kind of became somewhat of a
migrant farmworker traveling up and down
the state with the crops
japanese-americans quickly became
involved in all aspects of agriculture
from preparing the fields to sowing
seeds and bringing produce to market
recession time in nineteen thirties
[Music]
they've got pretty much every type of
vegetable different types of what is's
iceburg green leaf romaine lettuce green
cabbage red cabbage spinach cilantro
parsley celery broccoli asian vegetables
chinese napa cabbage bok choy and baby
bok choy despite being in demand as
workers Japanese farmers faced major
obstacles Japanese American farmers were
both admired and reviled for their
success white farmers needed them on
their farms to make them productive but
they resented the success that Japanese
immigrant farmers were beginning to
enjoy and it fed into a long-standing
tradition of anti Asian sentiment on the
west coast a 19-13 alien land law
blocked first-generation Japanese
immigrants from owning land because they
couldn't become US citizens my
grandfather they they had money when the
three peas were good and during the
Depression and people were selling some
of their ground and at that time he
bought put the name in his oldest child
which was my aunt who was eight or ten
something like that but she was still a
child after the 1913 alien land law
anti-japanese sentiment didn't decline
and by 1920 a new law was passed that
restricted the ability of american-born
children of Japanese immigrants owning
property so the vise on
japanese-americans owning property was
becoming ever more tight but Japanese
farmers still grew nearly 40% of the
produce in California by 1940 despite
the anti-japanese legislation then came
World War two President Franklin D
Roosevelt issued an executive order that
authorized relocating japanese-americans
to internment camps
evacuation more than a hundred thousand
men women and children all of Japanese
ancestry removed from their homes in the
Pacific Coast state to wartime community
it wasn't a good feeling because yeah
three or four your best friend was white
friend was over here you know they
didn't get moved out or anything we're
pretty good friends farmers had to
abandon their crops twenty-two million
dollars worth of produce was left in the
ground but it didn't go to waste the
government stepped in to harvest the
needed produce but farmers were never
compensated it's a very large proportion
of Japanese American tenant farmers who
didn't own their property were subject
to a new program that was run by the
wartime civil control administration
that took their land their farms their
equipment and transferred it to the
hands of white Americans who were not
being rounded up Japanese workers
continued to farm even after they were
incarcerated inmate labor was used to
keep camps running doing everything from
growing food to teaching children
refurnished all the labor to keep the
seigneur and y'all paid $7 monk the
average wage in 1942 was 156 dollars per
month during the latter years of being
in camps college aides people were
allowed to go to college in the interior
my father finished up at the Tulsa my
mother in Chicago so Japanese got spread
all over the place the people that
didn't have things to come back to you
basically stayed where they were after
the war many Japanese had no homes to
return to and most that had own land had
sold it before being incarcerated but a
few were able to resume farming thanks
to the generosity of neighbors who cared
for their property and returned it after
the war my grandfather he was a very
sharp man because he said that if we
left everything to one person you didn't
know what
so he left the trucks with one person
the equipment farming equipment and the
land with our neighbor here and the
animals the horses that they used to use
for some of the work to another person
well when they came back they they had
everything but except the horses even
those who came back faced an uphill
battle
my grandfather was actually the first
person back here in the Santos County
and they had to sleep in this house that
we were at now in the hallways because
they were afraid of being too close to a
window in case bullets came through the
window because there were shots being
fired up in the air they had a little
tough when they came back your cash-poor
and so it was good people in the
community that extended credit that
allowed our families to that was
themselves again the Akitas Hayashi's
and cobras along with others relied on
this collective to continue their
farming in an often hostile climate and
compete against larger farms meanwhile
corporate agriculture was swallowing up
small farms and the state was losing
farmland to urban development these days
many Japanese Americans are far removed
from farming choosing instead to pursue
professional careers Bryson Takeda is
continuing his family's legacy I do have
two kids of my own and I love to see
them have the opportunity to have the
farming lifestyle really family centric
family breakfast is spending time with
the family and if farming something they
enjoy it push them in that direction but
I'd hate to have them do something that
they don't love and most family farms
don't make it past three generations for
you to be in an area for for this long
and put down roots and in the same
industry I think we've been very
fortunate thanks for watching this story
is really about resilience in immigrant
communities in America and we'll be
following other immigrant groups for the
next few weeks so let us know in the
comments what you want us to cover and
don't forget to like share and subscribe